hello everybody welcome to the second
part of tutorial on characterization of
quantum devices by stefania I think
we're ready to start sue yes sure okay
welcome back everybody so just to recap
briefly so we left off talking about
randomized benchmarking and we saw how
randomized benchmarking allows us to
estimate the average error rate of our
average Clifford noise as long as
certain natural assumptions are met you
know gate independence of the noise that
the noise is independent of which
Clifford gate I'm doing time
independence Marco Vienna t I forget the
fourth one there was some fourth one so
now let's follow on that and ask
ourselves some natural further questions
so one we want to you know I said
complexity is really important in this
game so how expensive is benchmarking
can we characterize the complexity of
randomized benchmarking can it be used
for estimating fault tolerant quantum
computing thresholds what happens when
we break these assumptions that I
mentioned and also you know I alluded to
the fact that we're going to sort of
start on the two ends we're going to
work our way into the middle how can we
extend this tool so that we can learn
other things besides this one parameter
this average error rate of our average
Clifford gate so the first thing is
there are some known results on the
complexity of benchmarking that is how
many random sequences I need to sample
so recall there's two sources of
variants in a randomized benchmarking
experiment there's the different
sequences that were sampling how many
sequences you need to sample is one
measure of complexity that's like the
measurement complexity in the jargon I
discussed in part one and then there's a
sample complexity which is how many
different times don't need to sample
those things in order to collect enough
data so the first result is abound on
the measurement complexity how many
different sequences do I need to measure
in order to get and
estimate that you know is plus or minus
epsilon so we can characterize that in
terms of the variance the inter sequence
variants okay so there was some initial
work by Madison which gave very loose
bounds on these types of quantities and
that was followed up by a paper by Joel
Wallman and myself and I'll briefly
mention a paper that will hopefully be
out next week by Jonas helsen and others
which addresses this question of inter
sequence complexity so we're assuming
now that all of these nice assumptions
are met that we have time independent
gate independent noise what can we say
about the complexity in that case so we
can derive a general upper bound so the
trivial upper bound that you get on the
variance is order 1 it's a constant
which doesn't sound bad right if you're
a computer scientist in this audience
you're thinking wow you know order one
complexity is the best you could ever
hope for but we actually want to do
better than that because we're trying to
get something that's sensitive to the
fact that we're in this scaling limit
where are the average error rate is very
very small it might be showed data from
an experiment that claims 10 to the
minus 6 is their error rate right so if
we can if we can find protocols that are
improving as our gets smaller that would
be really good okay so we can actually
do better than a constant we can get
something where the variance scales like
em the sequence length times this
average error rate bar that was proven
in the second paper here and four cubits
cubits it turns out have a little bit of
special structure and you can improve on
this bound and you can show that under
some additional mild assumptions there's
like an additional small error term that
enters into this when you have large
span errors you can actually get
something which is M squared R squared
or just M R squared if the if there's no
spam at all and so this is a significant
improvement because it means that you
only need to take rather short sequences
like normally you might think well
if i'm going to estimate an error rate
of 10 to the minus you know six I'm
going to need to do sequences of length
ten to the six before I start seeing
those errors sufficiently that I can
sort of figure out that that is indeed
my error rate and this says no you don't
really need to do that an extrapolation
really does give you an accurate
estimate of those very very low error
rates ok so these results put the use of
randomized benchmarking at least in this
at least when the gate independence
assumption and the time independence
assumptions are respected it puts
randomized benchmarking on a very firm
theoretical footing and gives us
concrete guidelines for experimentalists
for how they need to pick the number of
sequences if they want to get some
target error rate because usually they
have some initial understanding some
ballpark guess for what r is so if they
plug that in they can get some further
estimate for how many sequences they
need to choose from these types of
estimates um so the bounds itself I mean
I have a big o here you can back out
constants from these arguments so what
do these bounds look like this is abound
so hopefully you can see it there's a
green line right here sitting above a
bunch of blue lines so what is this a
plot of the green line is the bound that
you get from this paper by Wallman and
myself these blue lines are a bunch of
randomly chosen noise channels okay so
this represents all of the channels that
live of distance our distance is a bit
of a misnomer because as I mentioned
before the average error rate is not a
metric so you know I say distance in
quotes these are all the channels that
are in that have average error rate R
with respect to the identity okay and so
we see that there are some channels at
least numerically which come very very
very close to saturating this bound okay
so this says that at least four cubits
and for short sequence lengths this
bound is extremely tight and gives very
good guidance for experimentalists for
how to choose sequence lengths
they'd also and so the actual number is
you know somewhere less than 100 it's in
it's in the tens right many tens right
so there are some new bounds which I'll
this paper is not quite out yet so i'll
just mention them briefly this has
recently been extended by helson at all
to multiple cubits and they improve a
lot some of the scalings had some
dimensional factors which we managed to
get rid of and so the new bounds are
effectively constant independent of
dimension and they still shrink down
they still had they retain the benefits
of this scaling with respect to our so
here are just some slides from this
paper which as I said is not yet on the
archive but will be soon showing how the
previous bound you know continues to
grow as a function of for example the
number of sequences or here is I can't
even read myself number of sequences on
a log scale in each of these different
rainbow colors is for a different fixed
average error rate alright so as the
average error rate goes down you do need
more sequences to certify that
particular average error rate but it
scales like a constant in the number of
qubits okay this x-axis here is the
number of qubits so these are very good
bounds and these are these are sort of
if you can't read that it is a little
bit small the numbers here are in the
practical range for what people are
currently working at the the top one
here is two times ten to the minus four
so these are sort of error rates that
people are doing in in you know
realistic quantum computing experiments
at least in the ones where people have
very high fidelity quantum gates okay so
we have some idea about the complexity
of benchmarking in this setting where we
respect all of the assumptions of gate
independence time independence etc and
where we're only worried about the
complexity of inter sequence variation
okay but as I said there's a second
source of noise and
the noise / sequence right if I want to
estimate the fidelity of a specific
sequence I have to sample that sequence
many many times because unless i managed
to magically get back in the same state
if you know if it was somehow perfect
there's always going to be a little bit
of noise and i have to sample to
estimate that probability so what can I
do in that case yeah this is reiterating
what I what I just said there's the
within sequence and the inter sequence
variants so I can use this other tool
which was developed by a grenade fairy
and Corey called accelerated randomized
benchmarking so there the philosophy is
to try to use some prior knowledge so
they cast randomized benchmarking into a
Bayesian framework okay so you have some
prior information about what your error
rate is maybe you have some spread okay
you always have prior information so
here the philosophy as well we should
use that prior information to get better
estimates and in particular if you don't
resample sorry if you don't recycle the
same sequence multiple times okay so you
add a new sequence every time you sample
all right this might be hard in some
architectures but not in all of them
because i'm going to show an experiment
where they actually did this then
actually you can you can do a full
Bayesian analysis and get a credible
interval for the estimate of the average
error rate okay so here if the sequences
are reused the inter sequence variants
dominates so then the philosophy is
don't reuse it okay so how does this
work it turns out that their protocol
well okay I already explained the
protocol their protocol is to just
resample a fresh sequence every time do
a bayesian update starting from some
prior okay that that's the point of the
paper and this is also where's Chris
this is in the queue infer package isn't
it yes it's also in that cumin for a
package that i mentioned earlier so so
what else is nice about this it turns
out not only is this optimal in some
sense for learning p it comes with
optimal error regions as well it come
with a Kramer ral bound which those of
you familiar with estimation Theory
Kramer ral bound gives you achieve abhi
lower bounds on variance of unbiased
estimators it can be it actually is a
little more general than that so this
gives you ways to check that you're not
fooling yourself okay so we saw some
fits where you know it's not totally
obvious that there wasn't some kind of
drift source or something like this if
you don't recycle your sequences you can
get this Kramer RAL bound which is a
certificate if you beat this crime
around somehow you're fooling yourself
you're not respecting the assumptions of
randomized benchmarking you need to go
back and think more carefully about
what's in your experiment okay so um by
using this Bayesian approach and adding
additional randomness you you get some
advantages by doing this like I said in
some architectures it's very hard to
change the measurement settings so for
example I know in Reiner blots group at
least in the experiments the way they
were running a few years ago the
reconfiguration time on their fpga to
reprogram a new gate sequence was on the
order of seconds whereas the resampling
time once they fixed a particular gate
sequence with something like a
millisecond or on that order and so what
that means is it's a lot easier for them
to resample the same sequence so for
them there that that trade-off was worth
making this trade-off of you know well
we don't get this Kramer ral bound
advantage we don't get this accelerated
randomized benchmarking advantage
because it would take too long for us to
do that but this is an experiment from
the Yale group Rob show cops lab where
they actually do resample fresh
sequences every time so it is possible
to work in this limit depending on what
experimental architecture you have and
it's actually the preferred setting that
you want to be in okay right so okay
comparing so now we've seen that you can
estimate are very accurately with pretty
low complexity so we want to now compare
this number to the fault tolerant
threshold right that's really what we're
all about we're characterizing
individual gates we want to understand
how we can take these numbers on these
individual gates and understand how they
compose in larger circuits okay that
means we have to connect to the fault
tolerant threshold somehow so as I said
you know mark will d ask this nice
question about well what about other
measures and the answer was well really
what we care about is things we can
measure and things that we can compare
to the threshold right and it's it's the
fact that we don't have one thing that
we can immediately measure that means we
have to work with multiple measures ok
so how what's the best way that we can
compare the diamond distance right which
is one particular way we can estimate
thresholds to this thing that we can
estimate in experiments the average
error rate so I mentioned this bound
from this paper that Joel and I wrote a
few years ago the bounds are pretty
loose right we know that the scaling is
in general saturated ok so the diamond
distance is only loosely related to the
average error rate we know that pally
noise saturates this lower bound so
Polly noise is what everybody uses in
their numerical simulations that's not
quite true as of maybe just last year
there were a few papers that really
started to look at coherent noise
sources there were some papers a little
bit before that that looked at amplitude
damping noise which is an incoherent
process but it's a non poly channel so
we're finally sort of starting to get
away from this pally noise paradigm and
trying to understand the effects of non
poly noise on channels and we're trying
to figure out well you know how far do
we have to go how large of a discrepancy
is there between the things we measure
and the things that we know certify
thresholds so ok let that brings us to
the topic of coherent noise so if I have
coherent unitary rotations over or under
rotations think of this is like a
calibration error in your device ok they
can in general be much worse right what
is the intuition for this well you know
if I have an unbiased random walk and I
take tea time steps I expect to be about
root tea away from where I started
whereas if I have some sort of bias
epsilon well I'm going to have I'm also
going to have some root tea behavior
I'm going to have tea times epsilon T
times the bias right so whenever you
have a bias it's going to add up
linearly okay so that linear scaling is
what happens when I have coherent
unitary errors all right so the two
types of noise coherent and incoherent
errors have radically different
worst-case behavior on quantum states
now you might say and you're right to
ask this question well why do I care
about worst-case shouldn't I only care
about average case I'll return to that
point in a minute but the point of this
slide is that worst case is in general
very very different from average case
okay so what happens when I have these
coherent noise sources in an actual
quantum device so we see this in
benchmarking experiments what happens is
the coherent errors it turns out lead to
a direct violation of the randomized
benchmarking assumptions okay so
coherent errors induce gate dependent
noise all right gate independence was
one of the fundamental assumptions of
randomized benchmarking and if you have
strong coherent errors you're going to
strong gate dependence you have strong
gate dependence you're done and here's
what happens over here this is from a
paper by ball at all here is something
where we respect the gate independence
assumption here's where we have some you
know large detuning error or coherent
error and we see a very large spread
across all the different sequences these
are the sequence Fidelity's for a bunch
of different sequences we see a really
large spread okay and so when you fit
this you might still see something
comparable to the original answer if the
average is the same you might get the
same answer but that average is no
longer a very good characterization of
the actual noise that you have in your
system all right you're going to need
something else we'll figure out what
that something else is going to be in a
second here's another these lines or
from actual experimental traces so these
are numerical simulations this is from
the figures from this paper by Fogarty
at all but the the lines themselves are
traces from this experiment mohona net
all here are some more numerical
simulations from a paper by Epstein and
we see that you know in general these
coherent errors leading to this
violation the gate dependence assumption
they
of break benchmarking a little bit okay
so this is this is known to be a problem
so yeah like I said we would like to be
able to pin all of this on coherent
errors okay I claimed there with the
culprit here is exhibit a right exhibit
a is a toy model which we can analyze
completely and we can analyze it
completely using this semi definite
programming characterization of the
diamond distance so those of you you
know the hardcore theorists in the
audience you're all hardcore theorists
I'm sure except those of you that are
experimentalists you know that semi
definite programs come with a dual
certificate which enables us to prove
upper and lower bounds on feasible
solutions and so that means that we can
we can compute you know we can compute
the diamond distance of very complicated
objects sometimes analytically okay so
if we do that we can compute so here
what is this a plot of this is a plot of
the log of the average error rate oh
sorry the log of the incoherent error
rate p it says his bit flips with
probability P and unitary over under
rotations by an angle Delta okay and so
on this axis is log P on this axis is
log Delta so going down here is smaller
and smaller incoherent errors going down
here is smaller and smaller unitary
errors okay and then up here is the
ratio log of the ratio of the diamond
distance divided by the average error
rate okay and down here where the
coherent where the incoherent errors
dominate you're fine the scaling is flat
okay up here we see a huge blow up okay
this says that the coherent errors are
dominant okay and we know that it's not
their dominant as soon as Delta is
slightly larger than P those things
dominate okay p is no longer a very good
metric if you're reporting incoherent
errors you're getting it wrong okay so
that also means as a corollary if the
traces of your benchmarking
experiment look like this as opposed to
this the number that you're reporting
that average error rate is not a good
characterization of your noise it does
not correlate well with the fault
tolerant threshold okay you need to do
additional characterization for that
number to have much meaning I mean you
can report it but it comes with a caveat
okay and you should mention that caveat
in your paper um amplitude damping it
turns out is much more benign and I
actually have an unpublished more
general proof of this this is a plot for
single qubit noise and in this paper by
cooing at all we proved we just proved
it for the single qubit amplitude
damping channel the point is this square
root factor which separates the
distinction between the diamond distance
and the average error rate in general we
can prove that that never happens for
noise that's dominated by an amplitude
damping channel okay so it really is the
coherent errors that dominate and by the
way you can decompose channels into
products of coherent errors amplitude
damping type you know you can do an
affine decomposition of a general
channel into rotations shrink right
that's a that's a shrinking is a
depolarizing channel maybe with multiple
axes together with an affine shift
that's what amplitude damping is right
and so shrinking and affine
transformation are not the culprit it's
the rotation that's the culprit ok you
can decompose general channels into that
and use this chaining bound so this is a
pretty general conclusion it's the
coherent errors this was this was
understood i should say by the pioneers
early on but it was not i think it was
understood conceptually this puts a very
fine point on that a very precise way of
explaining this so now let me go back to
something that I claimed which is that
you know why do we care about worst case
isn't it just the average case that
matters no it is not the case we really
do care about worst case all right I'm
actually a little bit pessimistic
there's growing optimism in the
community we're going to quantum
computers any day now i'm much more
pessimistic than the way i see general
opinion moving on the grounds that i
don't think people are comparing to
the right number these worst-case errors
which are actually the square root
there's the square root relationship are
the relevant numbers okay we've
understood that by now so here this has
been discussed in at least two papers
that I know of one by Poots wooly and a
recent one by Wallman here are some
numerics from joel Wallman that shows on
this axis are and on this axis the
difference in error probability for two
quantum circuits right so there's no
error correction in these circuits these
are sort of bare level circuits where
there's no error correction here i have
an ideal circuit and an ideal
measurement here i have a noisy
evolution and a measurement and you see
that when I have these unitary errors
the error probability really does grow
like it's substantial the stochastic
noise is down here very low error
probability you run these circuits
you're going to get the right answer
regardless okay but in the unitary case
these errors grow quickly okay so it
really is a problem okay so given that
coherent noise is a problem we need to
understand it we need to correct for it
we need to fix it what are some
proposals for doing that here's one
proposal it's something called the
unitarity so the precise definition
doesn't really concern us the point is
this if you look at the definition so
it's rescaled and shifted in a certain
way to make it bounded between 0 and 1
the point is it's a quadratic function
of the channel so here it depends on the
noise channel like e squared okay so the
average error rate depends on the trace
of the channel that's a linear function
of the channel it gives us average
information this is giving a second
moment information so it's telling us
something about spread ok so the
unitarity is a measure of noise that is
only sensitive to incoherent oice if I
[Music]
yeah I guess actually this is this has
been sort of Miss named in the same way
that relativity was Miss named and that
Einstein should have wanted to call it
invariance theory unitarity is invariant
under unit Ares so maybe it should be
you know invariants theory the invariant
measure or something so the point is any
unitary gate that I apply
i doesn't change the unitarity okay so
what that means is the following if I do
a standard benchmarking experiment and I
have some shrinkage or maybe some affine
shift benchmarking is sensitive to those
errors it's also sensitive to a rotation
error as well okay it's sensitive to all
those errors the unitarity is only
sensitive to this part that shrinks the
Bloch vector okay it's not sensitive to
the rotations at all so if I know both
of these numbers I can decompose my
sources of error and say this much
component is due to you know half fine
shift and shrinkage and this much is
related to rotation errors okay so this
gives me a measure that I can estimate
how much of my noise is due to coherent
errors okay and what's nice is there
exists a benchmarking like protocol
which lets me estimate this so this has
been deemed purity benchmarking this is
an experiment done in NMR in Raila
flaunts group you know here are these
benchmarking like these classic decay
curves that let us get an accurate
estimate at is parameter the unitarity
let me just sketch really quickly how
that works I mean you get this decay
curve the reason it's called purity
benchmarking is because you can relate
back to measuring the purity of this
state at the output I should say that a
nice feature of this unitarity is that
if you know both the unitarity and the
average error rate if you knew both of
those perfectly it constrains the
diamond norm up to constant factors so
there's no more square root scaling
anymore okay now it might be very hard
to get such an accurate estimate of both
of these but in principle you know the
first and second moments completely
characterize the diamond distance okay
right so it has a few other nice
properties this idea of purity
benchmarking so it correlates with but
is distinct from the average error rate
it also one nice thing it does is it
puts a lower bound on the optimal
achievable error that you could get if
you had perfect unitary recovery so if
you are able to do
arbitrary corrections to your gates and
suppose you knew the unitarity then the
unitarity tells you a lower bound right
so it says if you improve your
calibration perfectly how low can you
get your average error rate right this
is the min overall unitary corrections
of the average error rate puts a lower
bound on that okay so that's a
potentially useful thing to know because
it's so it's like I said it's
decomposing your error into coherent and
incoherent sources okay so that's purity
benchmarking that gives us a handle on
in coherent sources now there's a lot
more that we'd like to know about our
gates as well so I told you randomized
benchmarking gives us the average error
of the average Clifford gate but that
doesn't tell us anything about the
individual Clifford gates ok so we've
seen now gate dependence is a big deal
so how might we understand gate
dependent noise one idea for having for
how we might do this is this idea of
interleaved benchmarking which is due to
madison at all so the idea is we first
do a reference sequence we're so sorry
contrary to my other slides i I always
try to use the Kataya of convention of
time moving from right to left so that
it just looks like an inner product and
it's really nice these guys use the
opposite convention and I just took a
screenshot of their figure so so yeah so
time is moving backwards here so we do a
long sequence of gates and we do
benchmarking here prepare stateside
measures dates I that gives us a
reference fidelity for our average
Clifford gates and now we're going to
insert systematically a specific unitary
see ok it's one of our Clifford gates
and we think it's responsible for a
large amount of noise I'm going to
insert this and then I'm going to
compare the two GK curves so I have a
control and a variant and by looking at
the difference of those two curves
subject to some assumptions which I'm
not going to go into because I don't
really have time I can back out an
estimate for the error on the specific
interleaved gate so here is an
experiment that these guys did at IBM
where they actually estimate they have
two gates this is an pi over to rotation
about X a PI over to rotation about Y
and there's there's actually two decay
curves which are a little bit steeper
than this blue reference curve and so
they can actually back out estimates of
individual gates by using this technique
of in early benchmarking it has some
weaknesses as well it turns out that the
sometimes the assumptions you have to
make are a little too strong it can be
hard to back out an accurate estimate
using this technique but it's still a
useful technique nonetheless what are
some other things some other limitations
that we want to try to bypass with this
idea of benchmarking so I mentioned that
it's only good for Clifford gates well I
actually said you have to use a unitary
to design you you can't use a horror
random unitary well I mean you can but
then the problem is the inverse gate is
going to take as much effort as the
original sequence right and so it really
decreases your signal to noise ratio if
you were to try to do this ok so what
that means is randomized benchmarking
needs to use something like the clifford
group where you have an efficient way to
invert those gates so that means if I
throw a tea gate into the mix and I make
my gate set Universal it kind of spoils
this nice property of randomized
benchmarking so we needed an additional
trick so there's a couple different
tricks in the literature there's
actually an experimental paper that uses
yet a third approach by the Martinez
group which I should have cited on this
slide it slipped my mind so one
approaches by by two groups by the group
bet I QC and Joe Emerson's group and the
IBM group they call it dihedral
randomized benchmarking here we we pick
a different group that includes the T
gate but it still has the property that
it's not universal ok and so this is not
a tea design but it's somehow closed
it's closed in the following sense
instead of having you know a general you
know a general channel left over after I
do this averaging I'm left with a
channel that only has a couple of
parameters
okay and so I can do a slightly more
complicated fit funk like I have to do a
little bit more complicated data
processing you could do like a multi
exponential fit is one way that you
could do it but if I do that more
complicated data processing I can back
out the fidelity of atty gate okay so
it's not a to design it gives me like
extra parameters that I have to estimate
but I can then back out estimates for
individual t gate fidelity's and now I
can benchmark an entire set of quantum
gates a universal set of quantum gates
another idea by robin harper and myself
is to use its it's not a to design but
it's like a squared one design which is
somehow very close to a to design as
well but rather than being closed in a
sort of representation theoretic sense
it's closed in like an analytic sense so
you get some small epsilon error which
is very small under certain slightly
different circumstances so this is like
a complementary approach it complements
this dihedral idea I'm not going to go
into that but the point is just that we
can we can benchmark individual t gates
so now we can estimate Fidelity's
average error rates of universal sets of
quantum gates there's a there's a few
more variants as well there's probably
there may be even more in the literature
that I'm forgetting but these are the
last who i'll talk about and then we're
going to start to move on from
benchmarking because you probably all
sick of it one other one is leakage so
another type of error which wasn't
considered previously is if I have
leakage to some third state right so in
superconducting qubits you know they
have oscillators right what if I what if
I go to some photon number state that is
not a computational state or photon loss
if I'm you know if I have some you know
if I'm doing an optics type encoded
quantum system so there's a benchmarking
protocol where you can estimate leakage
rates similarly you can estimate logical
error rates it turns out to be a little
bit subtle this is still unpublished
work by Coombs at all logical randomized
benchmarking is exactly what it sounds
like it's randomized benchmarking on the
logical degrees of freedom one so one
nice thing about it is that you can
estimate probabilities of correctable
and uncorrectable errors separately if
you do it the right way so there is an
existing experiment which did there's
nothing wrong with that experiment but
we now have I think a better theoretical
understanding of what should be done in
the future for logical randomized
benchmarking and oh yeah the other nice
thing about this is that it's less
susceptible to gate dependent noise
because the syndromes itself when you
measure them you eliminate coherent
errors right you can't have a coherent
superposition of macroscopic we measured
syndromes once the once you've read the
syndrome out into your classical hard
drive you're not you don't have a
quantum superposition of those syndromes
anymore um so that turns out that that
cuts down on some of these problems with
the gate dependent knows that I
mentioned before ok let's let's move on
from randomized benchmarking now ok so
there's another idea um called direct
fidelity estimation which is the
following so so okay this other idea is
also going to allow us to estimate like
these t gate protocols it will let us
estimate error rates on quantum states
or on quantum gates that are not
necessarily Clifford gates it is
sometimes depending on the circumstances
more susceptible to span errors so it
has a slightly different domain of
applicability than randomized
benchmarking the basic idea is to
estimate fidelity using like a Monte
Carlo approach ok and this is from these
two papers by E Kyle you and myself and
Marcos de Silva and co-authors so in
order to describe this idea let me first
give you a sort of trivial algorithm
that constitutes Monte Carlo fidelity
estimation so I'm going to cheat I'm
going to use a quantum computer and I'm
going to show you how using a constant
number of samples I can get a great
estimate of the fidelity with which I've
prepared an arbitrary quantum state this
generalizes naturally channels as well
I'm not going to mention the channel
generalization it's a straightforward
generalization so suppose for the moment
that I'm trying to produce some pure
States I then this is the expression for
the fidelity so I'm given many copies of
the noisy version row but now i'm just
going to be able i'm going to give
myself magically the ability to measure
the POV em in the basis sigh 1 minus
sign right well i'm cheating right
because the whole point of being able to
produce this size you know it might take
a quantum computer to do that ok so this
is cheating but if I do that then I'm
just flipping a coin with some bias that
the bias is epsilon I repeat it one over
epsilon squared times to get an estimate
you know with accuracy epsilon ok this
is a cheating protocol to get the
fidelity to within accuracy epsilon but
it assumes the existence of a good
quantum computer but it contains a
kernel of truth so how do we how do we
improve on this protocol so the idea is
to expand the fidelity function into a
basis of observables that we have easy
access to in our experiment so in this
example I'm going to do it for the pally
group but you can do it for other basis
of observables that you have available
in your lab so for example coherent
state measurements if you can do
homodyne detection the same ideas go
through ok so so I'm going to expand row
the state in the pally basis ok I've
just done that expansion in the
orthonormal pally basis and I'm going to
define this thing here as its
characteristic function right it's just
it's basis expansion in the poly basis
the fidelity then looks like an inner
product between the characteristic
functions of these two two expansions
the expansion of cyan the expansion of
row if I have a pure state then this
thing is a probability density or
probability distribution rather and so
what i can do is i can multiply top and
bottom by i can define a variable X
which is the ratio of these two elements
and then I can look at the expected
value right I just plug this thing in
times this so this probability x this
the expected value of p times x sum over
all values is exactly the fidelity okay
so now i've rewritten the fidelity as an
expected variable an expected value of
some random variable which is a ratio of
these two quantities one of which i can
calculate write the denominator here
depends only on sigh my target state i
can calculate that i don't need to know
anything about my experiment i can
unconditionally calculate that the
numerator depends on something that i
can measure in an experiment the overlap
with some pow a measurement right i can
just measure this a bunch of times to
get an estimate you can compute the
variance of this estimator and you find
let me skip ahead let me skip these
slides for a second and say that you get
some answer for the complexity it's you
know in 1 over epsilon squared samples
you can recover an estimate of the
accuracy of your state row with respect
to the target States I unconditionally
there's a d dependence in general and
i'm ignoring the dependence on this
probability of correctness delta so
that's the punchline let me back up and
say what the caveats are so the caveats
are that you actually need to be able to
compute the coefficients in the pally
basis of your target state so if you
have a Clifford circuit or if you have a
stabilizer state or something like this
you do this efficiently if it's
something which is somehow close to a
Clifford circuit a Clifford circuit with
a handful of T gates in it you can do
this efficiently like a constant number
of T gates if it's something like a w
state which is not a Clifford circuit
but enjoy some other nice properties you
can do this efficiently um there's a
ovett should say caveat to caveat to is
that the complexity does depend on d i
showed you the complexity bound already
on the next slide um but all of that can
be done is pre-processing and it can all
be done in parallel so there's no need
for any complicated data analysis you
just pick which samples you're going to
do that's the monte carlo part and then
you go off and you do those measurements
[Music]
let me skip ahead a bit and just say
this entire procedure for Clifford
circuits the sampling the estimation
procedure the resampling of each
sequence to get the estimates it's all
polynomial time ten or twenty ten plus
yeah let me okay there's another
important direction in this field
Hamiltonian estimation as well as phase
estimation here are some nice references
I'm going to skip ahead and talk about
learning classes of states ok so now I
want to move into like we've estimated a
bunch of parameters that's what these
previous things were about now we want
to estimate not just parameters but
classes I want to define a class of
states I don't want to learn an element
of that class ok so there's lots of
examples of this in the literature
there's low rank states or low krause
rank quantum channels learning Clifford
circuits or Clifford gates actually
learning states that live in the
symmetric subspace learning matrix
product States etc etc I'm just going to
focus I don't have time to talk about
all of these so I'm only going to pick
two and because it's my talk I'm going
to pick two that I was involved in the
lower rank States and matrix product
States but all of these things are
really interesting and there's a lot of
good work on this in this general
direction ok so what is compressed
sensing tomography so it's this first
one on this list it's this idea of
learning a low rank state ok so I'm
going to try to learn a description of
an unknown state from within the on Zotz
class of states with low rank or
channels with low krause rank so few
krause operators so it turns out we can
do this very easily and there's a bunch
of really nice properties that this
enjoys so i can i can do all this with a
measurement complexity which scales only
with the dimension x the rank rather
than the dimension squared of the state
ok so it's linear in the dimension
rather than quadratic so it gives us a
quadratic speed up for states that are
close to low rank it reduces the sample
complexity as well from d to the
well the it achieves the known optimal
sample complexity if I were to do an end
copy joint measurement all right so
there exist protocols where I take all
end states I put them into a quantum
computer with a large register and I
make some huge joint entangled
measurement this works on single copy
States makes pally measurements and gets
the same asymptotic complexity up to log
factors so it's a much simpler way of
doing things it comes with rigorous
confidence intervals that has fast
practical heuristics as well I said you
know there's always this importance you
can prove your theorems but you also
better have practical heuristics so the
main idea is to just sample a sufficient
number of pallies and we have to reprove
the theorems using some very fancy
estimator which comes from convex
optimization in order to prove this and
you get a theorem of the form you know
if i have ordered d squared copies of
the state then i can reconstruct an
unknown state with low rank with
accuracy epsilon in the trace distance
one of the key proof techniques which
was proven by EK lees 0 is this idea of
the restricted isometry property which
says the following that you know so you
might think I'm measuring so few
observables on making so few samples how
on earth can I do this you know it's not
a well posed problem it turns out it's
sort of almost well posed so there's a
there's a pseudo inverse which has a
unique point in the manifold of low rank
states ok any Kylie you proved that
there's a very strong notion of this
that the pally operator is satisfied
called the restricted isometry property
and it gives us the strongest guarantees
that we know for this problem so here
are some
here is some an actual experiment which
was done by Ryan herb lots group on
seven ions and it shows so here is a
tomographic estimate of a noisy so this
is an estimator I think this is the
maximum likelihood estimator and you see
all kinds of artifacts everywhere and
here we see addy noised version which
comes from this compressed sensing
yesenia which just reconstructs the
lowest-ranked piece of the cross map so
it's learning the most relevant features
sort of bit by bit okay one other
interesting thing that we can do because
this has nice connections with many-body
physics as well as what norbert shook is
going to talk about next time this idea
of matrix product states so let me just
rather than define them say that matrix
product states form of variational on
Zots to describe states that have sort
of localized correlations so the
correlations are clustered locally okay
so if the correlations themselves are
local maybe I only need to make local
measurements and and you know stitch
those together to form some global state
it turns out that you can do this so the
idea is I'm going to make a bunch of
local measurements on this state okay
suppose for the moment that those
correlations are indeed locally
clustered then it turns out I can solve
the local consistency problem which is
in general like qm a hard I think turns
out for this special class I can
actually solve the local consistency
problem and I can find a global wave
function from from from within this
matrix product state class and I can fit
all of this data and find a global
description of an N cubed quantum state
this has been implemented recently in an
experiment again by the black group so
here they showed it's really remarkable
they did complete quantum state
tomography of a 14 qubit quantum state
by out putting it in matrix product form
right just to output a full rank density
operator of a 14 cubic quantum state
would never happen right that's just
really really too much information but
here you can sort efficiently a matrix
product state form and they
did local tomography on these systems
and then stitched them together using
tools for many body physics like the
density matrix renormalization group
algorithm and they were able to get
tomographic reconstruction and study a
quantum quench in their system okay
we're almost done I have just enough
time so we've sort of we started over
here we jumped all the way over here now
we're working our way slowly back to
this end the last couple things that I
want to talk about are the most the
highest complexity tools that we have
but they also give us access to the most
information okay so the first one is
called randomized benchmarking
tomography this is an idea due to Shelby
Kimmel at all so the idea is we're going
to try to get some of the same
advantages of randomized benchmarking
where we have these very long sequences
of quantum gates but we're going to try
to use we're going to use ideas from
interleague randomized benchmarking to
try to get individual estimates for the
overlap of our gates along different
directions in operator space okay and it
turns out if you do things correctly on
low on time I can learn the overlap of
my gates with any given clifford
operator so I can learn like the Hilbert
Schmidt inner product of my gate along
any Clifford direction and so if you do
this you can estimate lots of different
probabilities lots of different
properties of your underlying gates with
without falling prey to these spam
errors so this is a really nice protocol
that I think should see wider spread
experimental adoption and the other one
that has seen a quite widespread
adoption is this idea of gates at
tomography there's kind of two versions
of it in the literature the first is due
to Seth Merkel at all and the other one
is due to Robin blue coat and this is
more resource intensive than the
randomized benchmarking tomography
because it sort of does everything that
randomized benchmarking tomography does
but all at once the randomized
benchmarking tomography lets you kind of
pick and choose the amount of complexity
that you want gates act tomography says
i'm going to estimate every parameter of
every gate in my entire gate set
together with the state preparation and
the measurement errors and I'm going to
do it all at once in some big nasty
messy optimization problem unfortunately
for you they have some code that's open
source that you can download that will
assist you with this otherwise the
optimization is a big pain and so I
don't have time to go into the details
of how the guts of this protocol works
but if you do this so it's very it's
very resource intensive it's only been
done on one and two qubit systems but
you can get very accurate estimates you
can get estimates directly of the
diamond distance because you've
estimated all of your gates so you can
you can back out estimates of the
diamond distance for your specific gates
using this technique I'm going to just
show this cool video of one of the other
things this is some work by grenade
Coombs and Corey which shows how using
ideas that I've already mentioned this
idea of particle filtering I mentioned
this previously when I mentioned this Q
in for a package you know one of the
things that come came up a lot in this
talk is when we break these assumptions
you know we have to think hard about how
we're going to deal with that and time
dependence is one of the assumptions
that gets broken that I didn't really
talk about much I talked more about gate
dependence there are tools for dealing
with time dependence here we have
there's a really nice adaptive algorithm
from this paper which shows how we can
track estimates of states in real time
using this particle filtering approach
amount of time so let me just wrap up
and say okay the point is there's a
there's a variety of powerful protocols
for characterizing errors and quantum
gates so we have at the two opposite
extremes we have tomography and
randomized benchmarking there's a whole
lot of compelling intermediate models
where we're you know we're trying to
learn new specific parameters piecewise
or we learn specific on zotz
or here's the showing off my knowledge
of German on Zetas it should be
capitalized learning on Zetas about our
state and there's also lots of practical
heuristics which have been coded up by
various people you should check out the
Q infer package I even promised my post
doc I'd where the Kuhn for a shirt check
it out on camera there it is you owe me
a beer yeah so then yeah the other
message is the characterization isn't a
solved problem okay so we have all these
tools but you know I haven't told you
that we can deal with all of these
different problems the gate dependence
time dependence coherent errors we don't
have a specific way to measure you know
large circuits and understand the
diamond distance we can't say oh yeah
these guys are below the fault tolerance
threshold and they should just go ahead
and scale up fund these guys we don't
have the ability to do that yet so you
know that's the frontier and I hope many
of you will you know join me in
researching some of these questions in
the future thank
thank you Steve now it's time for
questions so I see okay seedless to so
you've given us a variety of ways to
evaluate error behavior could you
comment about the technologies we have
for example ESR versus photon methods oh
it's controversial yeah in particular
though I'd like to know which of the
methods we're using have systematic as
opposed to non systematic errors well
there's only there's only one real
approach that should be fun date and
that's maiorana fermions do what do you
think I deem I'm actually you know I
just kidding you know I thought that I
approach this like I don't you know yeah
i know im using the Microsoft yeah um
look I honestly I think every approach
has different strengths and weaknesses I
think to some extent the question is ill
posed like you know I can say there are
some things so superconducting qubits
for example which is you know one of the
darlings right now I think is that yeah
i mean the derivative is very positive
right it's like a solid state thing so
you know there's some hope that maybe
you can just scale it right up one of
the things that i think they struggle
with is coherent errors if you look at
these amazing experiments that John
Martinez does or Rob she'll call for any
of the other people who do really top
level superconducting qubits stuff I
mean in particular if you look at I'm
thinking of a Martinez group experiment
where you know they do have this large
spread they do have these coherent
errors they have low error rates you
know they have all kinds of advantages
but you know those are sort of things
they need to pin down so if you look at
other approaches they have other
weaknesses so I mean I think it's a
partial order there's no there's no
there's no unique best at this point
thank you yeah no second
you mentioned the differences between
the coherent errors and the incoherent
air Sam you really talked a lot about
how the coherent hairs were really
really terrible but there are techniques
for correcting coherent area code an
empty coupling and I mean if we if we
use these techniques in our algorithm
would this fix the problem can you
comment on that yeah so that's that's a
good point so there's a paper that I
didn't have time to talk about by
Wallman and Emerson that is it's
essentially it's dynamical decoupling
but it's it's applied specifically in
this context of compiling larger gates
so they do this idea of randomized
compiling they're actually some recent
work by Matt Hastings and independently
by Earl Campbell sort of hits on this
same idea that you know if you compile
things a bit randomly you can turn
coherent errors into incoherent errors
so in the Wallman and emerson paper so i
guess in the in the hastings and
campbell work they're thinking about
magic state distillation and if i if i
distill something sort of on average i
can get a square root improvement in my
accuracy the Wellman in Emerson paper
says well if I have multiple ways to
compile the same gate and I average over
that in a certain specific way and you
have to respect certain assumptions that
you have a class of Easy gates in a
class of hard gates so there are certain
caveats that go into that then you can
reduce your coherent noise and map it to
incoherent noise without increasing the
overall average error rate by much
alright that's the trick like you can
always do a longer sequence of gates to
reduce coherent error rates but then
your incoherent error rates are also
building up while you do these longer
sequences so you need to get a net win
in the end so certain regimes of this
randomized compiling scheme of almond
and emerson they can achieve that so
yeah I did I just didn't have much time
to talk about that you're you're
absolutely right there are tools and
techniques for doing that ok so more
questions
ok
yeah you talked about coherence a lot
but you didn't say much about
non-markovian tea or about correlations
among different gates are there
noteworthy results for characterizing
those yeah I mean I think they're there
are a few results there are some results
that that characterize spatial
correlations they're not currently
published it's a collaboration between
iqc and innsbrook but yeah there are
some results about that there are some
theoretical bounds as well I think
Marcus de Silva may have some work about
maybe she'll be Kimmel as well has some
work about theoretical bounds on these
types of questions it's a similar
situation to the coherent noise the
correlations are pretty bad and we need
to control for them and they're in some
ways harder to control for the
correlations so that's an yeah open
question go research that question
that's a hard question more questions
let's see what time
there's one minute for one question okay
then I ask myself so just a very quick
question you said about this channel
decomposition so I mean I'm aware for a
result for like Cuba channel
decomposition right in terms of like
unit or so this kind of shrinking and
translation is the same sinkholes for
like arbitrary dimension channels or um
probably because it's just an affine
space rights okay I can't imagine it
doesn't okay but lack you know lack of
imagination is not move I'm nearly a
certain III can't yeah yeah I mean
forgive this blogger kind of gives you
were denied intuitive way of looking at
it but okay probably yeah I guess we did
a compositional okay maybe yeah okay
then let's uh thanks Steve I gear for
great tutorial for you to remember oh
thanks